let's pretend you were going to run a
second crowdfunding campaign what would
you do the same and what would you do
differently this time that task seems so
daunting I would have a team you know I
ran my campaign 100% myself I didn't
have interns or anybody sending emails
on my behalf or anybody doing you know
help me with me with the video
production you know I wanted to I could
have probably but it was just one of
those things where you know you get
efficient at working at the speed of
thought and doing things yourself and
executing them that I ended up just
doing it myself but we ride to do
another Kickstarter campaign that would
definitely not be the case because you
know obviously there's a lot of things
that you need to be doing during the
campaign but there's a lot of things
that you could have done had you had
more hands on deck so I think having a
team is really valuable and that was one
of the challenges my project was that it
was just a script so I didn't have a
producer attached I didn't have actors I
didn't have other people who were you
know invested in the success of this
project who could help not only be on
screen in the video but also just with
the tweeting and facebooking and
spreading the word and reaching out to
contacts so that would be the main thing
is you know just having a team in place
that would have been nice for someone
that doesn't have a team let's suppose
maybe they've built an audience maybe
they've been really diligent with their
social media and again not to bash
social media i know i said before that
sometimes it seems like a giant time
waste but it is valuable and you do meet
great people all across the world so
what would you what would you say aside
from that what are some of the other
things i mean you had an amazing pitch
video and i think that's something a lot
of people miss they just put up a
trailer and they don't they don't
include themselves and so people saw
that okay well i want to invest in this
guy even if i don't know mm-hmm you know
i think for me it was something where i
was trying to check every box to give
myself the best chance of succeeding
with the campaign and one of those was
you know
making a video that was entertaining and
spoke to other creatives but not
actually having a trailer and not having
had anything shot that was a very
particular challenge and I think that as
the campaign was coming together if I
didn't feel like the video was turning
out ok that you know would have said a
lower goal I didn't have an audience
that I could reach via email email tens
of thousands of people you know right
when the campaign launched I would have
said a lower goal so it was kind of like
all those things together is what you
know I think made the campaign a success
so that it would you know not everybody
who bagged my campaign came from my
website you know and I think front
loading the work and planning it out is
really where the campaign is made or
broken for all up for a lot of time for
a lot of people as far as you know doing
the work on the video and planning out
you know making sure that you're running
the campaign during a time where there
is no national holiday at a particular
point where you're going to be trying to
raise money and everyone's gone or you
know if you're going on vacation
yourself in the middle that's not a
great idea you know just sort of having
that those strategies and front loading
the work is really a great way to you
know just to put yourself in the best
position
you